[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
copier qui s'appelait autrefois muscube
était hier encore une grande ville de
250 000 habitants capitale de la
Macédoine elle s'était magnifiquement
développée depuis la fin de la guerre
ajoutant à ses anciens édifices des
faubourgs de construction neuve mais on
ne reverra plus à scopier ce visage
d'hier un tremblement de terre l'a
changé en un désert de ruines
[Musique]
bagarre ouverte comme un cratère dont
l'horloge marque l'heure de la
catastrophe jusqu'au fond des banlieues
scopie et maintenant détruite ou
endommagée à
80%. à l'aube naissante une secousse qui
durera 20 secondes secoue la ville deux
nouvelles secousses quoiquent plus
faibles la chair les plus grands
édifices et des centaines d'immeubles de
3 à 4 étages ne sont plus maintenant que
des amas de décombres et dessous reste
encore sans doute des centaines de
victimes
les victimes à l'heure actuelle on a
retiré des décombres près d'un millier
de morts on a dénombré plus de 2000
blessés mais les ruines gardent
probablement encore des emmurer vivant
ou morts
[Musique]
devant l'hôtel macédonia les voitures
écrasées plus de 300 touristes
résidaient ici parmi lesquels plusieurs
familles françaises
le maréchal Tito est venu se rendre
compte de l'ampleur du désastre et
prendre sur place les mesures utiles car
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont maintenant sans abri et démunies de
tout
mais cette population n'aspire qu'à fuir
le lieu du cyniste le maréchal Tito a
décrété l'évacuation générale car la
menace des terribles séquelles de toutes
les catastrophes paient sur scopie
manque d'eau manque de vivre manque de
médicaments et par dessus tout l'horreur
possible du typhus
[Musique]
c'est dans une atmosphère de
contentement général que Messieurs
hariman délégué des États-Unis Andreï
romiko ministre des Affaires étrangères
soviétiques et lors d'un chamed
britannique on part à fait au Kremlin
l'accord sur la répartial des
expériences nucléaires sur ce problème
la France quatrième puissance nucléaire
aujourd'hui a marqué sa position par la
voie du général de Gaulle
nous participons
à la joie que le président Kennedy si
est localement exprimé avant-hier au
sujet de cet événement
mais sans méconnaître encore une fois
que cet accord de Moscou
puissent désobliger personne et en tout
cas pas nous
il faut bien voir
qu'il ne change rien
à la terrible menace
que les armements nucléaires
des deux rivaux
font peser sur le monde
en particulier sur ce des peuples qui en
sont des pourvus
c'est pourquoi
l'accord de Moscou je le dis franchement
au point de vue total et pratique pour
le monde
n'a pas n'accune importance réduite dans
ces conditions continuent de général de
Gaulle la France ne sera pas détournée
de ce doter des moyens atomiques
cependant elle serait disposée à
proposer aux trois autres puissances
atomiques certaines mesures effectives
et pratiques de désarmement
ce qui s'est passé à Moscou ne fait que
la confirmer dans cette intention
et elle compte avant la fin de cette
année
invité les États intéressés
à étudier en commun avec elle ce
problème essentiel
avant
que peut-être
il souhaite venus insolubles à son tour
témoin marquant de la progression
industrielle française les trois
centrales nucléaires que l'électricité
de France édifie sur les bords de la
Loire à Chinon ont reçu la visite de
Monsieur Georges Pompidou dans trois ans
c'est trois centrales edf-1 et des F2 et
EDF 3 totaliseront une puissance de 600
000 kW
cette visite constituait si l'on peut
dire le morceau de choix du voyage
d'information que le premier ministre
vient de faire entouraine et qui devait
lui donner l'occasion de rencontrer à
Montlouis son prédécesseur à Matignon
Monsieur Michel Debré autour d'un verre
de vin de la Loire bien entendu
manifestation de la participation
française à la conquête de l'espace les
techniciens du centre de lancement des
îles du levain ont procédé au tir de
deux fusées Bérénice dans le but de
mesurer l'échauffement consécutif à une
rentrée dans l'atmosphère à la vitesse
de Mach 14
[Musique]
fusée Bérénice ne sont autre que des
laboratoires volants capables de
transporter aux vitesses et aux
altitudes désirées le matériel a
expérimenté elles sont en quelque sorte
le banc d'essai préparatoires aux futurs
tentatives spatiales français
nouveau succès technique à l'actif de
l'hélicoptère lourd Super Frelon à
triple turbine qui s'était fait
remarquer au salon du Bourget pour sa
capacité de transport de charges de 4
tonnes et qui vient de battre coup sur
coup trois records du monde de vitesse
avec le record d'altitude détenu depuis
cinq ans par une Alouette 2 la
construction française détient donc
maintenant les deux principales séries
de records pour hélicoptère
il a suffit d'une étincelle pour
réconcilier les deux frères ennemis de
l'athlétisme français Michel JAZY et
Michel Bernard c'était un sel c'est
vadoux leur cadet le troisième homme qui
a su créer par des paroles amicales
résultat une finale du 1500 mètres au
championnat de France comme en enverra
sans doute jamais plus les deux Michels
ont pris leur responsabilité
l'un après l'autre l'un relayant l'autre
ils ont foncé sur la piste sans chercher
à savoir qui elle gagne
[Musique]
enfin jazzy et son démarrage éclair et
tout de même Bernard accroché à quelques
mètres derrière lui un spectacle
inoubliable qui va choisir un record
d'Europe et à Bernard la deuxième
meilleure performance mondiale de
l'année mais Vadoo le réconciliateur qui
termine 3e sera sans doute de mal
meilleur de tous
les bolides de grands-papa ont encore
bon pied bon œil et ça part au quart de
tour comme au 24 Heures du Mans enfin
presque
c'est dans la patrie de Rabelais à
contre que se déroule cette épreuve
d'endurance pour Tophe des toft qui ont
la coquetterie de rouler plein gaz
pendant trois heures d'affilée c'est
assez joli pour des ancêtres
et quand on va trop vite voilà ce qui
arrive
[Musique]
décidément le public est toujours sans
pitié
à cet âge-là on ne respectent rien à
croire que cette guimbarde est retombée
en enfance
et tout y est dans cette course c'est
comme au 24 Heures du Mans il y a du
suspense et des frissons dans les rangs
des spectateurs de quoi vous donner des
sueurs froides
[Musique]
l'arrêt buvette est obligatoire on
appelle cela faire le plein
il en est ainsi pendant trois heures au
bout desquelles les voitures terminent
quand même sont les chapeaux de roue
bien content d'avoir gagné et à l'année
prochaine
[Musique]